well i'm joined now by shadow
environment secretary jim mcmahon a very
good morning to you so the union's
asking questions over labour's handling
of the strike so first of all was sekir
stama right to sack the shadow transport
minister
sam terry
i mean first of all the trade unions are
doing a very important job at
representing working people that are
really feeling the pinch after 12 years
of a tory government where the economy
is stagnated and people are really
feeling the squeeze now in the cost of
living crisis and so the trade unions uh
with that collective power of workers is
very important and i've been a member of
the trade union since i was 17 in my
first job i believe in that collective
power and i believe in workers coming
together what the labour party needs to
do is to look to the country and to
convince a country that we are to be
trusted with the nation's finances that
we are to be trusted with public
services and that we would to be trusted
for their families and that's about
convincing them that we're ready to
govern and so what the role that we're
playing is about holding the government
to account of course but it's also about
looking to the country and saying there
is an alternative to the tory uh flat
line in the economy there is a
alternative to the torah is completely
stripping out our public services and
there's an alternative to a government
frankly that is standing by during a
cost of living crisis that's really
hitting working people
well if the unions are as you say
good at representing working people why
is it such a bad thing for a labour
politician to to show their support on
the picket line
this is not about whether somebody was
on a picket line or not it was about as
i understand it the broadcast round uh
that was done with our authorization and
all of the assignments were collective
responsibility uh on the shadow cabinet
and that's very important and when that
isn't followed then the chief whip has
to take action to ensure that discipline
can be maintained because if we can't
organize ourselves in opposition then we
can't look to the country and say that
we're ready to govern and that's the
critical thing i do not want to go to
another general election to wake up on
that friday and find that the tour is a
won again we need to look to the country
and show them that there is an
alternative and when it comes to being
on the side of working people listen he
was the labour party the right at the
start of the year of the year was called
for a windfall tax on the oil and gas
giants it's a labour party that voted
down the national insurance increases
and it's the labour party that are
bringing forward plans to deal with the
cost of living crisis that people are
going through
but do you think the unions feel
supported by labour
i've been the trade unions from all the
relationships that i've had and you know
right throughout my uh political journey
we've always told shoulder shoulder with
our trade union colleagues they're an
important part of the labour family and
we have different roles to play in this
the trade unions of course has to
organize and make sure that workers have
that collective voice when they don't
feel that they're being listened to but
i look to the conservatives and say well
where are they where is branch at on the
rail strike for instance when he's
completely missing in action instead of
making it better he's making it worse by
fanning the flames and i think the
government will need to step up now and
recognize that the country is grinding
to a whole under their leadership and if
they don't show leadership we are going
to head into the summer and into the
winter with further industrial action
and further cost of living crisis
hitting households
well yes and we talked to dave ward of
the communication workers union earlier
you talk of other industrial action he
said he was talking to other unions
about forms of collective action what do
you make of that do you support some
kind of collective action and what would
that look like
it feels to me as all the conservative
government is right in that to be honest
through their actions through their
words
the way that they are tackling the cost
of living crisis the way they haven't
got a plan to control inflation and
critically the way they haven't got a
plan to grow the economy i think all of
us now have looked at the last 12 years
at the stagnation in the economy where
we haven't seen the growth that really
delivers a quality of life for working
people where people are seeing their
wages stagnate and people don't think
that they're able to get on that
generational improvement that was a
british promise that if you work hard
and roll your sleeves up you can get on
in life has been denied people for the
last 12 years and people have absolutely
reached the end of their tether and it's
for the labour party to offer an
alternative which is what we're doing
our plan for government will see a fresh
start for britain uh changing the person
at the top of the conservative party
will not deliver the change his country
requires and it's very important that we
keep focused on that but it's for the
government of the day the conservative
party to deal with the cost of living
crisis to make sure that people can
afford to put food on the table because
if they don't because they are going to
naturally want the pay increase okay and
i want to ask you about the cost of
living in just a moment but what about
this issue of collective action we had
john mcdonnell the former shadow
chancellor on this program yesterday he
was saying that he would back a general
strike or coordinated action so would
you back one too
i want to see strike action avoided at
all costs i don't think anybody wants to
go on a picket line when they want to go
and do a day's work but people are
forced to do that when the negotiations
reach a position
a blockage
and so the question then is well what
can the government do to remove that
blockage to get the trade unions around
the table with the employer to try and
negotiate a solution that works for
working people and when the government
don't do that but even worse make it
much harder on the sidelines when
they're fanning the flames of dispute
doesn't help anybody so i won't see all
strike action avoided completely because
that's not what working people want
there's not a single person on that
picket line that wouldn't rather be in
work but they cannot continue to feel
the cost of the cost of living crisis
where things are getting worse and not
better so the government do need to
convene people they do need to find a
way through that and they need to bring
inflation under control to make sure
that people aren't feeling the squeeze
in the way that they are
how do you keep inflation under control
if you're paying higher wages
but that isn't what caused inflation
that we're seeing today these calls for
higher wages are as a result of the cost
of living crisis they are not the cause
of the cost of living crisis uh that we
see today listen my brief covers uh food
uh and drink which is essential for
people and we talk about gas and
electric bills we talk about council tax
national insurance and the rest but i do
think people feel the price of food
increase acutely when they go to the
supermarket and they're trying to
balance the family finances and
increasingly people can't buy the things
that they used to buy people are
skipping meals and actually what i
notice in my local supermarket is that
the food bank donation basket on the
other side of the till is far emptier
than it was before because people
haven't got their head room to be able
to donate even to the local food bank
what could the government have done they
could have taken action on the
fertilizer crisis they could have taken
action on the co2 crisis they could have
taken action on the labor crisis where
we have labor shortages which means that
people are going hungry on one hand but
there is literally food rotting in the
fields on the other there are forty
thousand pigs being called because we
haven't got the butchers in this country
and the cost of everything is going up
for producers as well as retailers and
consumers
well yes and energy bills are going up
the prediction is they'll go up even
higher than we had thought so what needs
to be done about it what's labour's plan
of action
well we need our short-term plan which
is the windfall tax on oil and gas
giants we need not to make it worse than
it is and that's why we voted against
the national insurance increase that's
really hitting families at a time when
they need help and not more taxes going
out of their wage slip but we also need
a long-term plan listen there are too
many homes in this country that are not
insulated that means that people are
paying far more for energy than they
otherwise would do because the
government have completely fallen back
uh on the the progress that was being
made under the previous labor government
to make sure that homes are of a decent
standard
if we're able to insulate homes we'll
save people hundreds of pounds a year on
energy we can reduce the amount of gas
that we use by 15
that reduces our dependence on
russian gas for instance but then also a
really ambitious plan to make sure that
we have new nuclear new on and offshore
alternative fuel as well to make sure
that we have that long-term plan because
we are in this crisis for a reason and
the reason is that we have not invested
in our communities we have not invested
in energy and the benefit of course
isn't just that we have less
bills to pay in terms of gas and
electric it's creating those decent
working-class jobs in every one of our
regions so britain can grow and thrive
together
jim mcmahon we appreciate your time this
morning thanks very much indeed for
joining us